la fábrica de carbón de abdica mantuvo a
flote en la ciudad ucraniana de la línea
del frente durante toda la guerra aquí
prefieren no hablar del conflicto
sin comentarios
verdad noticias la vida ya es bastante
dura
el ejército ucraniano mantienen sus
posiciones en las fábricas en ruinas
aquí los intercambios de fuego son casi
diarios el enemigo está a menos de 100
metros porque tuvo unos chiquitines no
tiene ningún seguimiento pueden
dispararle a cualquier cosa en cualquier
momento para ese oficial la cuestión de
una invasión de Ucrania por parte de
Rusia es obsoleta
estoy diciendo que va a haber un ataque
que los rusos están acumulando sus
fuerzas por eso no lo creo sufrirían
demasiadas perdidas
no se ha movido significativamente en
casi 7 años pero la situación sigue
siendo inestable hasta que Rusia hacerte
la orientación proxidental de Ucrania y
está hacerte la ocupación de parte de su
territorio por las puertas del Kremlin
a 5 km de la línea del frente New York
es una ciudad ucraniana
y los miembros de este centro
comunitario al igual que los
estadounidenses están preocupados por la
concentración de tropas rusas en la
frontera
en esta ciudad los últimos atentados
contra zonas habitadas se fueron en 2019